hallo leute heute werden wir euch die
100 wichtigsten werben im deutschen
vorstellen und dieses video haben wir
zusammen mit vielen gemacht vielleicht
kennt ihr noch jeremy von ceiling hallo
gary barlow kaffee und in diesem video
haben wir nicht einfach nur zufällig 100
werben ausgewählt wir haben oder
vielmehr journey hat untersucht welche
werben am häufigsten benutzt werden und
dafür hatte unter anderem alle
transkripte von easy german untersucht
und geguckt welche werben werden am
meisten in unseren videos auf der straße
benutzt und diese top 100 werben stellen
wir euch heute vor los gehts los geht's
wir fangen an mit dem meistgenutzten
werk nummer eins ist sein hobby
ich bin ich war ich bin gewesen
dani ist neu in berlin
sie war noch nie zuvor hier
nummer 2 haben
ich habe ich hatte ich habe gehabt
ich habe angst vor spinnen
ich hatte schon immer angst vor spinnen
nummer drei werden to become oder tugend
ich werde ich wurde ich bin geworden
janosch wird immer süchtiger vom spielen
mit seiner neuen vr brille
er ist gerade erster in seinen lieblings
spiel geworden
nummer vier können to be able to ich
kann ich konnte ich habe gekonnt
michael kann keinen tag ohne kaffee
leben
hat schon einmal versucht einen tag ohne
kaffee zu leben aber er konnte es mit
[Applaus]
nummer 5 machen to do to make ich mache
ich machte ich habe gemacht
manuel und ich machen seit zwei jahren
einen podcast wir haben schon über 250
episoden gemacht nummer sechs müssen to
have to ich muss ich musste ich habe
gewusst
emanuel muss immer kartoffeln essen
er musste heute schon dreimal in den
supermarkt gehen um neue kartoffel
produkte zu kaufen
nummer 7 sagen to say ich sage ich sagte
ich habe gesagt
jeremy sagt dass er gerne viel arbeitet
ich arbeite gerne viel
der imi sagte dass er gerade an einem
konjugation trainer arbeitet nummer acht
gehen to go ich gehe ich ging ich bin
gegangen
ich gehe nicht gerne in dunkle räume
ich bin schon einmal in einen dunklen
raum gegangen und da war natürlich eine
spinne
nummer neun
geben
ich gebe ich gab ich habe gegeben bei
jeremy gibt es heute kein mittagessen
denn er muss programmieren
es gab bei sealink noch nie so viel zu
tun wie jetzt
übrigens jeremy arbeitet immer noch sehr
viel und mittlerweile hat er diesen
kommunikationstrainer von dem wir euch
früher erzählt haben fertiggestellt und
wenn ihr lust habt die verben aus diesem
video intensiv selbst zu üben dann
können wir euch dafür unsere app ceiling
empfehlen ihr könnt die app jetzt
herunterladen und zwar kostenlos im
google place tor und im app store und
ihr findet darin die
2200 wichtigsten deutschen werben die
ihr können müsst um gut deutsch zu
sprechen
und jetzt ganz neu gibt es darin dieses
besondere feature den
kommunikationstrainer probiert den mal
aus denn jeremy hat daran wirklich sehr
hart gearbeitet
carré ich arbeite gerne für
nummer 10 wollen ich will ich wollte ich
habe gewollt heute wollen manuel und ich
eine neue podcast episode aufnehmen
manuel wollte schon immer seinen eigenen
podcast haben vor zwei jahren ist sein
traum endlich wahr geworden nummer elf
kommen
ich komme ich kam ich bin gekommen
danny kommt aus taiwan
sie ist gerade aus den usa gekommen und
für einen neuen job nach berlin gezogen
nummer 12 sollen to be supposed to ich
soll
ich sollte ich habe gesagt janisch
sollen wir im haushalt helfen aber er
spielt lieber in der virtuellen realität
janus sollte schon vor zwei wochen den
müll raus bringen doch er hat immer
weiter gespielt
nummer 13 sehen
sie ich sehe
ich sah ich habe gesehen
ich sehe überall spinnen
[Musik]
eigentlich habe ich nur eine
bananenschale gesehen nummer 14
mögen
ich mag ich mochte ich habe gemacht
ich mag ja
aber ich mochte es lieber als janisch
noch keine vr brille hatte nummer 15
finden to find ich finde ich fand ich
habe gefunden
emanuel findet eine kartoffel in seiner
kapuze und
jetzt hat er auch noch einen in seinem
schuh gefunden
nummer 16 wissen
ich weiß ich wusste ich habe gewusst
diese schüler wollen alles über die
deutsche sprache wissen
sie haben schon immer gewusst dass sie
unbedingt deutsch lernen wollten nummer
17 glauben to believe ich glaube ich
glaubte ich habe geglaubt
manuel glaubt dass er für die podcast
aufnahme alles gut geplant hat er hat
schon immer an eine gut verordnung
geglaubt nummer 18 lernen zu lernen
ich lerne ich lernte ich habe gelernt
danny lernt in berlin jeden tag etwas
neues
jetzt hat sie gerade gelernt wie
unfreundlich die berliner sind nummer 19
dürfen
laut tu
ich darf ich durfte ich habe gedurft
heute darf jeremy sich endlich einmal
entspannen es ist sonntag
er dürfte sich doch nicht entspannen es
gab einen bug reports
nummer 20
denken
ich denke ich dachte ich habe gedacht
emanuel denkt schon wieder an kartoffeln
jetzt dachte er gerade an bratkartoffeln
nummer 21
heißen to be called oder termin ich
heiße ich hieß ich habe geheißen der
lehrer dieser klasse heißt herr hammel
ski
nummer 22 sprechen to talk to speak ich
spreche ich sprach ich habe gesprochen
manuel und ich sprechen schon seit 30
minuten miteinander
jetzt haben wir gerade darüber
gesprochen dass manuel gerne immer alles
ganz genau plant nummer 23 tun tudou ich
tue ich tat ich habe getan
die schüler tun alles um die vier
deutschen fälle zu lernen sie haben
schon viel getan um sich den domina tief
genitiv dativ und akkusativ zu merken
nummer 24
fahren drive
ich fahre ich fuhr ich bin gefahren ich
fahre glücklich in einem sauberen
spinnen freien auto
ich bin glücklich in meinem auto
gefahren aber es war nicht spinnen frei
nummer 25
schreiben to ride ich schreibe ich
schrieb ich habe geschrieben michael
schreibt seine einkaufsliste
er hat seine einkaufsliste geschrieben
und natürlich stand nur kaffee drauf
nummer 26
lassen to leave oder toilette ich lasse
ich ließ ich habe gelassen
gott eine spinnen frisur ich lasse vor
schreck mein handy fallen
ich habe mein handy fallen gelassen
verdammt jetzt gibt es ein spinnennetz
auf meinem handy nummer 27 fragen
ich frage ich fragte ich habe gefragt
denn ii fragt sich warum die deutschen
so viele regeln haben sie hat sich auch
gefragt wie man sich diese ganzen regeln
merken soll
nummer 28
bekommen to get ich bekomme ich bekam
ich habe bekommen
jeremy bekommt oft nachrichten von mir
ich habe allerdings noch nie eine
antwort bekommen
nummer 29 nehmen
ich nehme ich nahm ich habe genommen
heute nimmt sich herr husky zeit um
einen neuen fall der deutschen sprache
zu erklären den fall schati wir wollen
der walzer dies die schüler sind
schockiert hat herr mehr ski drogen
genommen
nummer 30 sich freuen to be happy to
enjoy
ich freue mich ich freute mich ich habe
mich gefreut ich freue mich denn heute
will die amish mit mir spazieren gehen
ich freute mich nicht lange denn jahres
brachte zum spazierengehen seine vr
brille mit
nummer 31
zeigen die show ich zeige ich zeigte ich
habe gezeigt
manuel zeigt und seinen letzten einkauf
er hat uns seine top 5 kartoffelgerichte
gezeigt
nummer 32
essen
ich esse ich aß ich habe gegessen
emanuel ist sein drittletztes
kartoffelgericht
bratkartoffeln
manuel hat schon einen ganzen teller
bratkartoffeln gegessen aber dann hat er
noch hunger auf kartoffelsalat bekommen
nummer 33 arbeiten to work ich arbeite
ich arbeitete ich habe gearbeitet
jeremy arbeitet heute zur entspannung im
park
verdammt es gab einen grund warum er
normalerweise immer zu hause gearbeitet
hat nummer 34
stehen
distanz ich stehe ich stand ich habe
gestanden
die schüler stehen auf ihren stühlen um
gegen den deutschunterricht von herrn
hamas wie zu protestieren
erst stand nur eine schülerin dann
standen plötzlich alle schüler auf ihren
stühlen
nummer 35 bringen to bring ich bringe
ich brachte ich habe gebracht ich bringe
journey pizza denn er hat mal wieder den
ganzen tag den schreibtisch nicht
verlassen
ich habe journey schon oft pizza ins
büro gebracht
nummer 36 kennen kino ich kenne ich
kannte ich habe gekannt
ich kenne meinen eigenen man nicht mehr
er kennt nur noch die virtuelle realität
nummer 37 benutzen to use to you to life
ich benutze ich benutzte ich habe
benutzt
der nie benutzt gerne einen roller um
zur arbeit zu fahren
oh
nein die unfreundliche frau ist wieder
da danny hat mit ihrem roller den ewig
benutzt
38 bleiben to stay ich bleibe ich lieb'
ich bin geblieben
die schüler protestieren immer noch doch
der hammer ski bleibt cool er erklärt
dass das mit dem fall stativ nur ein
scherz war soll das deutsche humor seien
die schüler bleiben skeptisch
nummer 39 leben
ich lebe ich lebte ich habe gelebt wenn
du in berlin lebt siehst du viele
interessante dinge in der u bahn wenn du
noch nie in berlin gelebt hast könntest
du hier überrascht werden nummer 40
gucken look to watch ich gucke ich
guckte ich habe geguckt
typisch deutsch diese frau guckt böse
weil sich jemand nicht an die regeln
hält diese frau hat wahrscheinlich schon
immer böse geguckt nummer 41 stellen
oder sich stellen die put to place ich
stelle ich stellte ich habe gestellt
yano stellt sich auf sein laufband um
sport zu machen
natürlich stellte er sich mit seiner vr
brille auf das laufband
nummer 42 hören zu listen ich höre ich
hörte ich habe gehört
die amish hört musik und tanz dazu
wow solche musik hat er noch nie gehört
wir machen eine kleine pause und in
dieser pause möchte ich euch noch mal
vorstellen wie ihr mit seal eng und
diesen werben aus diesem video genau
deutsch lernen könnt auf siedlern gibt
es eine work up section das ist
eigentlich wie ein online wörterbuch ihr
könnt dort alle verschiedenen wörter
finden ihr könnt auch aldi werben aus
dem heutigen video nach häufigkeit
geordnet sehen und ihr könnt dort
verschiedene übungen machen ihr könnt
zum beispiel einen kommunikationstrainer
benutzen und damit die konjugation der
verben in verschiedenen zeiten und
verschiedenen personen üben
nummer 43 spielen to play to act ich
spiele ich spielte ich habe gespielt
früher spielte janisch konzerte im
echten leben jetzt spielt er virtuelle
konzerte nummer 44 kaufen zu bei ich
kaufe ich kaufte ich habe gekauft
daria kauft sich ein typisch deutsches
spiel es heißt pochen
nachdem sie das spiel gekauft hat lädt
sie ihre freunde zum spielen ein
nummer 45
passieren meppen
es passiert es passierte es ist passiert
michael passieren immer lustige dinge
beim kaffeetrinken
es ist ihm schon öfters passiert dass
der kaffee auf dem schreibtisch umkippt
nummer 46
verstehen to understand
ich verstand ich habe verstanden
manchmal verstehe ich nicht warum manuel
immer alles so genau planen muss ich
habe noch nie verstanden wofür man so
viele listen braucht
nummer 47
wir reden des pik zu tag ich rede ich
redete ich habe geredet emanuel ist
nicht nur kartoffeln er redet auch gerne
darüber er hat schon so oft über
kartoffeln geredet dass er ein berühmter
kartoffel experte geworden ist nummer 48
schaffen der
komplette create ich schaffe ich
schaffte ich habe geschafft der husky
schafft es endlich die schüler zu
überzeugen
er hat es geschafft die schüler setzen
sich endlich wieder hinz und verzeihen
ihnen den schlechten scherz nummer 49
halten
bolt ich halte ich hielt ich habe
gehalten als kartoffel experte hält
emanuel viele vorträge
er hat auch schon mal einen vortrag über
den perfekten kartoffelsalat gehalten
nummer 50 trinken
to drink ich trinke ich trank ich habe
getrunken anno trinkt eine große flasche
milch in der u bahn sie haben einen
schnaps getrunken
nummer 51 treffen und sich treffen zur
hit to meet ich treffe ich traf ich habe
getroffen
daria trifft sich heute endlich mit
ihren freunden zum spielen
daria und ihre freunde treffen sich bei
benjamin
nummer
52 lesen geriet ich lese ich lass ich
habe gelesen ich lese ein buch zur
konfrontationstherapie
ich habe ein kinderbuch über spinnen
gelesen aber es hat nicht geholfen
nummer 53 nennen they'll be called ich
nenne ich nannte ich habe genannt was so
ein mann kommt in den zug um die
fahrkarten zu kontrollieren man nennt
ihn kontrolleur
eine person die kein ticket hat nennt
man schwarzfahrer
nummer 54 führen to lead to guide ich
führe ich führte ich habe geführt
janosch führt beim kochen spiel
und er freut sich schon denn er hat noch
nie bei einem spiel geführt und auch nie
bei einem spiel gewonnen
nummer 55
brauchen zenit ich brauche ich brauchte
ich habe gebraucht michael braucht mehr
kaffee er hat heute erst sechs liter
getrunken
nummer 56 stimmen youtube oder tobi
korrekt ich stimme ich stimmte ich habe
gestimmt
und übrigens das stimmt gar nicht dass
ich schon sechs liter kaffee getrunken
habe heute
nah gut das stimmte wirklich nicht es
waren nur 5,5 liter kaffee nummer 57
wohnen
ich wohne ich wohnte ich habe gewohnt
dummy wohnt erst seit zwei wochen in
berlin vorher hat sie in den usa gewohnt
nummer 58 helfen to help ich helfe ich
half ich habe geholfen jamie hilft mir
meine spinnenangst endlich zu überwinden
das hat leider nichts geholfen
nummer 59
erzählen hotel ich erzähle ich erzählte
ich habe erzählt
janos erzählt allen dass er die besten
karten hat ich hab das besten land
janisch hat auch erzählt dass er das
spiel gewinnen wird
nummer 60
erreichen richie rich ich erreiche ich
erreichte ich habe erreicht
ich erreiche sie mir mal wieder nicht
jeremy erreicht mich immer wenn er pizza
braucht
nummer 61
vorstellen und sich vorstellen to
introduce yourself und to imagine ich
stelle vor ich stellte vor ich habe
vorgestellt
michael hat eine panikattacke er hat
sich gerade vorgestellt dass er keinen
kaffee mehr hat
nummer 62 schienen
to
drag drop
ich ziehe ich zog ich habe gezogen
petja zieht eine neue karte er hat eine
sehr sehr gute karte gezogen
nummer 63 versuchen 23 ich versuche ich
versuchte ich habe versucht
ich versuche es noch mal
ich habe versucht eine plastik spinne
anzufassen und es hat fast geklappt
nummer 64 laufen
doktorand operate ode to flow ich laufe
ich lief ich bin gelaufen
es läuft immer besser für
pcs lief lange zeit gut für janisch aber
dann hat sich das blatt gewendet
nummer 65
gewinnen zu bin ich gewinne ich gewann
ich habe gewonnen die schüler gewinnen
einen preis bei deutsch wettbewerb herr
hammler ski ist stolz er hat noch nie
etwas gewonnen
nummer 66 suchen to search oder to look
vor ich suche ich suchte ich habe
gesucht denn je sucht nach einem
supermarkt
verdammt sie hat am falschen tag gesucht
nummer 67
erklären 2x plain ich erkläre ich
erklärte ich habe erklärt
ein mann erklärt danny das sonntags alle
geschäfte in deutschland geschlossen
sind der mann ist echt nett er hat er
auch erklärt dass er selber vor ein paar
jahren nach deutschland eingewandert ist
und dass sie sich keine sorgen machen
soll wenn am anfang vieles fremd und
ungewohnt ist
nummer 68
entscheiden oder sich entscheiden
to decide ich entscheide ich entschied
ich habe entschieden zu hause freut sich
herr husky immer noch dass seine schüler
in deutsch wettbewerb gewonnen haben er
entscheidet sich seine schüler nie
wieder mit schlechten witzen zu nerven
um seinen humor zu verbessern hat sich
herr husky für einen helge schneider
marathon entschieden
nummer 69
wählen
ich wähle ich wählte ich habe gewählt
beim kartenspiel musst du manchmal die
richtige karte wählen
anno hat die falsche karte gewählt er
hat gerade verloren
nummer 70 liegen juli
ich liege ich
ich habe gelegen jeremy liegt auf dem
sofa um einen mittagsschlaf zu machen er
lag auf dem sofa als er plötzlich eine
idee hatte
nummer 71 meinen tüv termin
ich meine ich meinte ich habe gemeint
ich meine dass janisch viel zu viel zeit
in der virtuellen realität verbringt
janosch meint dass ich endlich auch mal
seine vr brille ausprobieren soll
nummer 72 verlieren toulouse ich
verliere ich verlor ich habe verloren
die amish verliert überraschend das
pochen spielen
er ist total in feucht darüber dass er
verloren hat
nummer 73 studieren destani ich studiere
ich studierte ich habe studiert
nach dem verlorenen spiel studiert
janisch die spielstrategie
nachdem er alles ausgiebig studiert hat
will er nochmal spielen nummer 74 setzen
to sit down to put to place ich setze
ich setzte ich habe gesetzt denn je
setzt sich in ein café um kuchen zu
essen
nachdem sie sich gesetzt hat erklärt er
die kellnerin dass sie keine selbst
mitgebrachten getränke im café
konsumieren darf nummer 75 hoffen zu
hoch ich hoffe ich hoffte ich habe
gehofft dass plastik spinnen experiment
ist gescheitert
aber ich hoffe trotzdem weiterhin auf
eine welt in der menschen und spinnen
friedlich koexistieren können nummer 76
vergessen to forget ich vergesse ich
vergaß ich habe vergessen ich vergesse
manchmal dinge
und nein ich habe vergessen bei unserer
podcast aufnahme das mikrofonkabel
einzustecken nummer 77 sitzen
ich sitze ich saß ich habe gesessen
manuel sitzt am tisch und kann es nicht
fassen
wir haben hier über eine stunde gesessen
und geredet und haben gar nichts
aufgenommen nummer 78 einladen to invite
ich lade ein ich lud ein
ich habe eingeladen emanuel lädt zu
seiner ersten kartoffel ausstellung ein
er hat auch michael eingeladen
79 beschreiben to describe ich
beschreibe ich beschrieb ich habe
beschrieben michael beschreibt die
perfekte tasse kaffee er hat die
perfekte tasse kaffee nicht nur
beschrieben sondern auch eine formel
dafür entwickelt
nummer 80 schauen anschauen und sich
anschauen t look to watch ich schaue an
ich schaute an ich habe angeschaut du
schaust dir gerade dieses video an
81 ändern change ich ändere ich änderte
ich habe geändert jenny möchte endlich
sein leben ändern und weniger arbeiten
er ist im urlaub und hat seine
einstellung zum arbeiten total geändert
nummer 82 besuchen visits ich besuche
ich besuchte ich habe besucht
michael besucht die kartoffel
ausstellung von emanuel
er hat noch nie eine so schöne
ausstellung besucht
nummer 83 nutzen to use oder toyota
ich nutze ich nutzte ich habe genutzt
in berlin nutzen einige leute die man
sogar für ihren umzug diese gruppe hat
die u bahn genutzt um tische stühle und
eine pflanze zu transportieren
nummer 84 kochen
ich koche ich kochte ich habe gekocht
emanuel hat zur feier des tages seine
berühmten kartoffelpuffer gekocht
er hat auch einen kartoffel tee gekocht
für den kaffee süchtigen michael eine
gelungene abwechslung nur noch 85 feiern
tools celebrate ich feiere ich feierte
ich habe gefeiert
in den letzten zwei jahren haben wir
viele zoom partys gefeiert hier haben
wir gerade die veröffentlichung von
ceiling im app store gefeiert das ist
natürlich eine passende gelegenheit um
euch nochmal daran zu erinnern dass ihr
all diese werben und übungen dazu in
unserer apps finden könnt ihr könnt
sieling im browser benutzen
unterschiedlich dotkomm und ihr könnt
die app herunterladen im app store und
google place tor und es gibt darin viele
kostenlose funktionen
um mit diesen werben weiterzulernen
übersetzungen anzuzeigen die vokabeln
regelmäßig zu wiederholen und als
mitglied bekommt ihr sogar noch mehr
funktionen wie zb einen
kommunikationstrainer nummer 86 fallen
bevor ich falle ich viel ich bin
gefallen
matthias handy fällt auf den boden vor
lauter panik ist matthias auch auf den
boden gefallen nummer 87 bauen zu bild
ich baue ich baute ich habe gebaut ich
baue eine mauer aus müll damit janisch
sich endlich um das müllproblem kümmert
janas bleibt unbeeindruckt er baut
lieber den vorsprung in seinem spiel
weiter aus
nummer 88
entwickeln to develop ich entwickle ich
entwickelte ich habe entwickelt heimlich
entwickelt jeremy im urlaub neuen code
obwohl er im urlaub war hat er schon
wieder gearbeitet und neue features für
sie lang entwickelt nummer 89
erwarten to expect ich erwarte ich
erwartete ich habe erwartet die manuell
erwartet ein paket
das hat er nicht erwartet aber es
gefällt ihm trotzdem nummer 90
bezahlen
ich bezahle ich bezahlte ich habe
bezahlt
danny möchte für kaffee und kuchen mit
der kreditkarte bezahlen doch die
kellnerin sagt hier hat noch nie jemand
mit einer kreditkarte bezahlt wir nehmen
nur bargeld
nummer 91
verkaufen
ich verkaufe ich verkaufte ich habe
verkauft
panisch verkauft seine vr brille um mehr
zeit mit mir zu verbringen
harnisch hat seine brille schon verkauft
als ich ihm eine überraschung zeige
nummer 92
tragen to carry to wear ich trage ich
trug ich habe getragen
emanuel trägt sein neues t-shirt jeden
tag aber jetzt erst so lange getragen es
wird zeit für ein frisches t shirt
nummer 93
planen zu planen ich plane ich plante
ich habe geplant
manuel plant dass ich nie wieder etwas
vergessen darf
er hat geplant dass ich ab sofort bei
jeder podcast aufnahme mit einer
checkliste arbeiten muss nummer 94
danken
ich danke ich danke ich habe gedankt
michael hat schon wieder keinen kaffee
mehr
doch dann kommt er nie und bringt ihm
neuen
michael dank germany für die rettung in
letzter sekunde
nummer 95
füllen zu viel ich fühle ich fühlte ich
habe gefühlt
danny fühlt sich manchmal noch fremd in
berlin aber gleichzeitig hat sie sich in
den letzten wochen immer besser gefühlt
es gibt noch so viel zu entdecken nummer
übernehmen to take over to adopt ich
übernehme ich übernahm
ich habe übernommen
die armee übernimmt langsam die
gewohnheiten von janisch er hat auch
seine spielsucht übernommen
nummer 97
erinnern to remember ich erinnere ich
erinnerte ich habe erinnert erinnert ihr
euch noch an verb 13
jetzt habt ihr euch gerade daran
erinnert dass ich angst vor einer
bananenschale hatte
98 merken to notice to realize ich merke
ich merkte ich habe gemerkt
jeremy merkt dass man in der virtuellen
realität auch arbeiten kann
er hat so lange gearbeitet dass er nicht
mal gemerkt hat dass es draußen dunkel
geworden ist
99 lieben dich
liebe ich liebte ich habe geliebt
janisch liebt die neue zeit mit mir ich
liebe jetzt nur noch die virtuelle
realität
wir haben es geschafft hier ist nummer
100 er kennt to recognize the real life
ich erkenne ich erkannte ich habe
erkannt die amish und ich erkennen dass
wir den kampf gegen die virtuelle
realität verloren haben wir haben
erkannt dass die zukunft begonnen hat
das waren die top 100 werben und wenn
ihr jetzt immer noch zu guckt dann
gratulieren wir euch ihr habt sicher
einiges gelernt und ihr wollt vielleicht
noch weiter lernen dafür empfehlen wir
euch die app auszuprobieren die german
entworfen hat sie denn dort könnt ihr
die wichtigsten deutschen werben lernen
und auch die konjugation aller werben
üben viel spaß damit probiert das mal
aus der links hier unten